[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I would like to welcome
you all to the Authors Talk
for "Firewall."
We have Jack Nolan here, who,
in addition to serving in the US
military as a propagandist, is,
as people do in Los Angeles,
is an actor.
So I'm hoping for an
entertaining and fascinating
presentation, and
then it will be Q&A.
So without further ado, Jack.
[APPLAUSE]
JACK NOLAN: First, thank you
all so very much for having me.
We are in an interesting
situation in our country
right now, aren't we?
Several intelligence
agencies have
alleged that a foreign
power has exerted influence
upon our voting system in order
to get their favorite candidate
in office.
Now, I really don't want to
get into the question of which
candidate we prefer, whether
on the left or the right.
This is an American problem.
When you have a foreign
power doing that,
it affects the legitimacy
of our entire government.
The tool that they use to do
this is, in a word, propaganda.
Now, our founding fathers--
Washington, Jefferson,
Franklin-- geniuses all--
they built a republic
that has not only
survived, it has flourished,
spread through the world,
defeated slavery,
communism, fascism.
It's vital.
And it preserves our
freedoms, our way of life,
and our ability to live
in this free society--
affects us every day.
And that's terrific.
The problem is there are always
authoritarians out there.
The US military exists
because of that.
And having somebody like
Vladimir Putin come in
and affect our
election results--
well, obviously,
it's unacceptable.
Unfortunately, even
if these allegations
are proved to be
true, and Mr. Trump
was to be ejected from
the Oval Office tomorrow,
the problem, the central
problem, remains--
propaganda.
Vladimir Putin has shown us
a weakness in our system.
In their genius,
our founding fathers
could not have foreseen in
an era when ponies carried
the mail, a time of 20th
century propaganda raised
to the power of 21st century
communication technology.
We are unprepared for this.
And not meaning
to sound paranoid,
although I inevitably
always do, they'll be back,
and there will be more of them.
The Saudis, whoever,
will also try
to interfere with
our system in order
to get their preferred
candidates elected.
How do we fix this?
Propaganda, when you
really start studying it,
is interwoven into the
fabric of our lives.
We really can't
dispense with it.
And honestly, it
does a lot of good,
and it serves a lot of
important economic functions.
I'm not advocating that
we, well, outlaw it--
a little bit of regulation, a
little bit of corralling, sure.
We could stand that.
But to try to fix this
problem through legislation--
well, it's not going to work,
not and keep a free country.
Besides, let's be frank--
trusting the Democrats
or the Republicans
to fix the problem or
propaganda is ludicrous.
They're not upset
that the United States
populous was propagandized.
They do it all the time.
They're more like royalty
trying to run poachers off
of their hunting grounds.
They're upset that
somebody else horned in
on their target audience.
With apologies to Harry
Truman, this time the buck
stops with us.
We must understand propaganda.
We must study it.
I believe that the principles
that I teach in my book
"Firewall-- the Propagandist's
Guide to Self-Defense"
should be required reading
to get a high school diploma.
When I was in
college, I remember
taking a wonderful class
in Aristotelian logic,
argumentative logic, learning
about fallacies, and so
forth and so on.
And I remember
thinking, this shouldn't
be a college elective.
This should be taught at
the high school level.
This should be taught
to high school seniors.
Well, I feel the
same way about this.
And in fact, I'm
hoping to develop--
it's called a module--
four-week module, two-week
fast track for high schools.
And I would be very reassured if
that information was out there.
So what is this information
I'm talking about?
How much time do we have
because it took me five hours
to do the audio book?
The whirlwind tour, ladies
and gentlemen, pay attention.
What is propaganda?
Well, you can look it
up on the Wikipedia.
You can look up
in the dictionary.
You'll get all kinds
of definitions.
My favorite definition is
the simple almost brutalist
military definition--
any message that serves
the needs of the sender.
Any message that serves
the needs of the sender
is, by definition, propaganda.
Propaganda is a or any message
that serves the sender.
Repetition is also a
valuable tool in propaganda.
So when you have a little
girl look up at you and say,
would you buy me some
ice cream, please?
That's propaganda.
It's a very simple propaganda--
rudimentary.
But it's very effective, as
any parent will tell you.
Or if I say to you, buy my book.
Yes, that's propaganda.
I get $3 a pop.
But I'm really more interested
in getting the information
out there than I
am getting that.
And at least I told you
what I was when I started.
But when you have
a message like vote
for this candidate or a
message like buy our product,
buy our service, eat
at our restaurant,
that's also propaganda.
Advertising is a
subset of propaganda.
It's a little brother.
Big brother propaganda went
to work for the government
and is working extensively
for people like North Korea.
Little brother advertising went
to work in the business world.
And that's fine.
There's nothing wrong with
advertising and making money
so long as you're
telling the truth.
So the first tripwire, the first
wall that our personal firewall
incorporates is the
message that we have just
received propaganda.
Does it serve the
needs of the sender?
But that begs the
question, doesn't it?
Who is the sender?
And when you start
asking that question,
you'll discover
how many messages
you get every day where
the sender's signature has
been effaced, the serial
numbers have been filed off.
Most recently, of
course, I doubt
Mr. Putin signed the messages
he sent to the United States.
So it puts you immediately
into the thought pattern
of a detective-- cui bono?
Who benefits?
Buy the person you are engaged
to a diamond engagement ring,
not signed De Beers.
The third barrier--
is that source,
once you've identified
it, credible?
For example, does anyone
remember Baghdad Bob back
in the year of Saddam Hussein?
That guy rapidly
lost his credibility.
He may have had some
at first, and he
lost it quick to the point
where he became a laughingstock.
That is what happens when
you lose credibility.
So news organizations are
very jealously guarding
their credibility, as, for
example, Dan Rather learned,
to his discomfort, back in 2003,
when he published information
that turned out to be
spurious with CBS News'
imprimatur on it--
very important for organizations
like CNN, the New York Times
to maintain their credibility.
Those news organizations
that handle the extremes
like Occupy Democrat or
Breitbart-- not so much.
Is the sender credible?
And you don't want to lose
your credibility if you're
going to be a propagandist.
Why did this person
send me this message?
Very important question.
Let's look at the news.
The news, including creditable
organizations like CNN,
always have an agenda that
they're not telling you about.
That agenda can be as
simple as sell newspapers,
get hits on websites.
Therefore, their
headlines are going
to be sensationalist-- this
horrifying new development.
And certainly, you're going
to find even more of that
the more you get to the
extremes and the less credible
the source is.
Why did this person
send me the message?
The news organizations can alter
public opinion without lying--
without lying and without
jeopardizing their credibility.
How?
By choosing very
carefully what truths
they're going to
communicate to you.
Now, fortunately, we live
in the era of the internet,
where truths are out there.
The question is, can you find
them amidst all the noise?
But if something is good news,
well, it doesn't get covered,
does it, because that
doesn't sell newspapers.
The fact that, for example,
the crime rates are down
to historic lows, so
I understand-- well,
that doesn't sell
the morning paper,
does it, or nowadays,
the feed sites?
So yes, all of these
messages that you received
through the media, through
the advertisements,
and through propaganda
organizations
run by governments--
you have to ask
why did they send this message?
Did this message come
to you repeatedly?
That's one of the first and most
valuable and important signs
because propaganda
is repetition.
Propaganda is
repetition-- repetition,
repetition, repetition.
When you're driving
down the freeway,
and you see the same
billboard over and over,
that's deliberate.
When you're watching
the television,
you see the same commercial,
or you know, YouTube,
and you're watching the same
commercial over and over,
that's deliberate.
They want to bang into your head
their slogan or their jingle.
Is anybody old enough--
were most of you raised
here in Los Angeles?
Do you remember-- I would pay
real money to have this jingle
effaced from my memory--
Pete Ellis Dodge, Long Beach
freeway, Firestone exit,
south gate.
I see we have some
here who remember that.
I wish the men in black would
come with their neuralyzer
and blink that right
out of my head.
I can never get rid of it ever.
Some of you who are older
may remember plop, plop,
fizz, fizz, and you know
exactly what follows--
oh, what a relief it is.
Ladies and gentlemen,
when I say that phrase--
plop, plop, fizz, fizz--
I have just activated
a pop-up in your brain.
It's a full audiovisual
presentation
with music and sound effects.
You can see the pill
dissolving in the water.
Now, if somebody did that to
your computer, you'd be upset.
How did this slip
past my antivirals?
How did it slip
past my firewall?
How is this, now, slowing
down my processing power
and my memory, even
though I've got plenty,
and interrupting me
while I'm trying to work?
You'd be angry.
How much more angry
should you be that they
put this in your head?
Did you give informed consent?
Did anybody ask you
permission to do this to you?
And that's just advertising.
Advertising is
relatively harmless
compared to big government.
So the final point--
when you know that you're
dealing with propaganda,
the only way to deal with
it is to deny access.
As you've seen, if you
are repeatedly exposed,
it gets in your
head deliberately
because you've got very
high-powered psychologists
behind this.
Deny access.
That's what the people in those
swing states should have done
and I'm sure they
would have done
had they known that the
messages they were receiving
came from Vladimir Putin.
And that's the skill that we
all need to development in order
to fight off this
problem and to be sure
that our opinions in all their
diversity really are our own.
And once we've done
so, then we can
approach the real
problems of our world
with clear heads, clear eyes.
One last thing I
want to communicate--
I've given you the
bare essentials.
My name is Jack Nolan, and
I am a trained propagandist,
graduate of the John F.
Kennedy Special Warfare Center
and School, and
afterwards, I went off
to work in the film
industry, where
I saw propaganda being made and
insinuated into our television
and features.
And I'll be glad to talk
to you all about that.
The thing that I can't
communicate, even
in book-length form, is how
to think like a propagandist.
Does anyone here
remember a film called
"They Live," produced by John
Carpenter back in the '80s?
In this-- not a very
good movie, mind,
but it's a lovely metaphor.
The main character had a
set of special sunglasses,
and when you peer
into these sunglasses,
you could see the world
in a different way.
And he tried desperately to
get the people around him
to put on the glasses, to
see the world as he saw it.
Well, that's very
much how I feel
because I think a propagandist,
and I see the world
in a slightly different way.
And now, I know that you have a
lot of very smart people here--
marketing people here, for
example, psychologists--
and they see the
world in a similar way
that's slightly different.
If you don't have this
training, listen to them.
But at the very least, have a
listen to what I have to say.
My audio book is
available for like $3.
The electronic reader
version is available for $3.
You'll come away thinking
slightly differently.
You'll come away, I pray,
thinking like a propagandist so
that, yes, there will
be some steps taken
to try to prevent
Putin and the others
from interfering with
our next election.
But if we don't put down
our own personal firewalls,
the next guy foreign agents
put in the White House
may not be, forgive
me, a bumbler.
He may be a competent
authoritarian
like Juan Peron or
Francisco Franco,
and then, ladies and
gentlemen, the jig is up.
I see we have two minutes left.
We have some very intelligent
people in this room.
I'm looking forward to hearing
some wonderful questions.
Our nation is at stake.
Impress me.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I'll start out
because I'm holding it.
Can you talk a little bit
about some of the propaganda
you perpetrated?
It could be for good,
not necessarily for evil.
JACK NOLAN: I can give
you a brief overview
of what PSYOP units do.
Now, mind, I don't
oversell myself.
I'm no war hero.
I served with the 353rd
research and analysis company
here in Seal Beach and
when they inactivated
with the 15th tactical
up in upland California--
both fine units.
PSYOP deals with
foreign personnel,
whether you're dealing
with enemy combatants
or you're dealing with
civilians or enemy combatants.
We have rained artillery
down upon an Iraqi unit.
It's reduced to 50% strength.
We rained down upon these
little comic strips,
and these little comic strips
provide explicit instructions
on how to surrender
safely and why
you want to because we have a
good reputation, or at least
we did.
I'm an MP.
Don't get me started.
Abu Ghraib.
So and they,
therefore, surrender,
which means that they are
not fighting to the death,
we're not having to fight
people to the death,
and lives are saved.
Now, this is a weapon system,
classified as a weapon system.
And we're prohibited
from using it on you,
but the point is lives
were saved on both sides.
And I think everybody can
get behind that, no matter
where they stand on the
interventions in the Gulf.
Another example might be
interfacing with civilians.
Hey, folks, this is
our main supply route.
Please don't drive here.
Please don't walk here.
Even if you're a
refugee, we really
hate picking you out
of our tank treads.
Sorry, black humor.
All right, that's
what PSYOP units do,
and I was involved in that,
in the production of it--
researching and profiling
target audiences when
I was in the research company.
Tactical PSYOP is a little
bit more boots on the ground,
using loudspeakers.
As an example, you wheel
up a loudspeaker up
to some enemy unit, and you play
the sound of tanks going on.
And they think, oh,
we're being attacked.
No you're not.
It's a loudspeaker, fine.
You do that two
times, three times,
they start getting used to it.
By the 30th time, it's
a real tank company.
So yeah, there's a lot of wicked
supervillain stuff going on
here.
But the things that I would
like to tell you about
are the things that I
saw in civilian world.
I was on the set of a television
show-- no names, please.
Here's the DP saying--
I'm standing in, so I'm right
there on top of the action.
Here's the DP saying, OK,
so the bartender pours
the Drambuie in one hand,
the Coke in the other.
We pan down from that
to the drink, then
over here to our actor
sitting in the booth,
and I get my $25,000, right?
Now, a side fact--
I resent this because
he's getting 25 grand
and not sharing it
with us when we're
in this de facto commercial.
I've complained to
my guilds about it.
It's a long story.
But I mean, also,
look how simple
it was for them to slip a
Drambuie and a Coca-Cola
commercial right there
into your television show.
And I can show you
that on Netflix
right now when you
think you're watching
a commercial-free show.
No, there's no such thing.
Another one that I
was involved in--
some of you may remember
"Superman Returns."
And there's a scene
there where Superman
lands a plane in the stadium,
and a kid yells out, Superman!
I was right there when that
was being filmed, by the way.
And you look it up,
you'll see there's
a guy right behind him holding
a big cup marked Bud Light.
They're using Superman
to sell alcohol to kids.
But nothing has changed.
Back in 1980, I
remember "Superman 2"
when he was fighting
General Zod.
General Zod punches
him and slams him
into a great big Marlboro truck.
Now we're using Superman
to sell tobacco to kids.
Must I quote Kevin Spacey?
That's wrong!
So those are examples
that I've personally seen
and examples of some things
I've had of my part in.
One last example-- feature
film that I was involved in--
again, no names, please.
My job is, simply, to
type away at a computer.
And they set the camera
right here next to me, great.
Set guy puts an open
can of Sierra Mist
right there next to me.
Well, maybe it's his drink.
I'll just move it aside.
Nope, he puts it right back.
Ah ha!
That's product
placement, and you've
got to give me a lot
more money to associate
my face with that product.
They replaced me.
Did that answer your question?
Great, next question.
AUDIENCE: I want you
just to follow up
there, since you were on the
subject of product placements,
is that something that's
been going on forever,
or is some of that more of a
reaction to things like TiVo
that would let you skip ads
that were put in overtly?
JACK NOLAN: I can't speak
authoritatively on that.
I can say that I have an eye--
my special sunglasses
for this sort of thing.
Let's go back to Casablanca.
Everyone seen it?
Wonderful, I love this film.
That is great
propaganda, by the way.
That is propaganda that
inspires us to be our best.
I love this.
But in the midst of it,
they are showing people
constantly drinking
and constantly
smoking, even Ingrid Bergman.
Now, yes, they're in a bar--
Rick's Cafe Americain, sure.
But the point is, they're
reinforcing the norm
that everybody smokes
and everybody drinks all
the time, including the women.
This wasn't always so, and
now it's certainly not so.
And if you watch the
film now, you look
and you think, whoa,
what's all this?
So yes, there is product
placement even back there.
Now, you look at things today.
I remember watching "Superman"
back in '78, '79 back
in the movie theaters.
I'm an old guy.
And there was a Cheerios box
right there next to Ma Kent.
And you look at--
I was in a TV show--
again, no names.
Lovely scene, arguing
between a couple--
it happens take place
in a Nissan dealership.
And this was about 2008,
2009, I'm going to say.
So yeah, it's a
consistent thing.
It's always been there.
And it may always be there.
The exceptions, thank heaven,
are wonderful fantasies
like Star Wars or Lord of the
Rings, where you can't really
slip a Cheerios box in there.
Does that answer your question?
Very good, anyone else?
Please.
AUDIENCE: I'm interested
in this deny access step,
and I'm wondering
by what mechanism
do we achieve that because,
since everything that we see
around us is basically a form
of propaganda and everybody
has a lot more money and
willpower than we do?
So the deny access step
seems like kind of a way
to just get into this
extreme form of isolation,
and that seems kind
of dangerous also.
So how do we do that?
JACK NOLAN: That is
an excellent question.
I myself have to wrestle
with that every day.
Now, there's no way to
absolutely deny access,
obviously.
You're a person living
in the modern world.
And I wrestle with this.
I can't go out of my apartment
without seeing billboards.
And every time I see one, I
have this parenthetical message
in my head-- made you look.
So it's like a constant
warfare, and I really
do feel like my force
fields are up all the time.
It's like this
pressure, and it makes
me feel like a foreigner
in my own culture.
And I don't like
feeling like that.
But at least I know that
that kind of advertising
is relatively harmless.
When you get into watching a
political debate on television,
you can feel them
trying to channel you
into left audience,
right audience
and then trying to encourage
your brand loyalty.
And that's harmful.
You've seen the rise
of polarization.
You've seen that
it's very difficult
to have a conversation
with somebody who
holds a different political
view because they immediately
become defensive and hostile,
and often, so do you.
So how does one deny access?
Well, the simple and
obvious tools, of course--
don't watch
commercial television.
Watch it on Netflix.
Read a book.
Except I remember
one time I opened up
a '70s copy of William
Goldman's "Marathon Man,"
and right there
was a Marlboro ad.
Great.
Fortunately, that
practice is gone.
Ad blockers on your computer,
using a secure browser.
I, personally, use
Firefox, but I'm
going to bow to the superior
experience of everybody
in here.
Adblock Plus is still, despite
recent issues, still very good.
I'm able to watch YouTube
without commercials popping up.
That's helpful.
Just being aware and
finding every way
you can deny access without
cutting yourself off.
Yes, it requires effort,
and it requires thought,
and it requires application.
But it's something, I
feel, that has to be done.
It's a survival
skill in our culture
so that you can know that the
opinions that you've formed
and the choices that you make
day to day-- economic as well
as political choices.
Whether you go to
Harry's Burger,
where a man is his own
boss, or whether you
go to McDonald's, where a
person is putting together
your food by factoring rules
written by some guy in Ohio--
are those choices your own?
If you have the
firewall in place,
and if you try to deny
access, you can at least
feel a little more confident.
Now, Chris here reminded me
of a wonderful principle from
my military days--
defense in depth--
the idea that you have
multiple layers of defense
in order to secure something.
My car was stolen, so I put on
an alarm, and I have LoJack,
and I have all these
different tricks
I've pulled to keep it
from being stolen again--
multiple levels of protection.
It's the only way to be sure.
Even then, it's not
foolproof, but it's better.
And so that's the only
answer I can give you.
And honestly, one
of things I hope
is that people will use my
book as a kind of framework
and that people who are
much smarter than me
like Noam Chomsky will come in
and say, hey, good start, kid.
Let's build upon this format.
Let's build upon this
framework and that,
by the time they're done,
people like you, for example,
coming in and telling us about
search engine optimization
so that a particular
sponsored product comes up
in your search list first.
I know nothing about this.
I need good people like
you to write that chapter.
And more and more contributors
will come and more and more
people sharing their experiences
with things like denying access
so that this firewall can
get stronger and stronger
and it becomes less and less
associated with me and more
of the kind of
collaborative effort
you see at Microsoft,
where they've
got Windows Defender, written
by many, many more than one
programmer.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: I have
so many questions,
but one of your
things is evaluating
the credibility of sources.
And certainly, in
the last year or so,
fake news has been very
much one of the topics.
And there are
various attempts now
on the part of like Facebook
and other companies,
including our own,
to try to figure out
how you might identify this.
So how can you tell if
a source is credible?
JACK NOLAN: A very
good question.
Well, first off, remember
that the political parties are
trying to ensure brand loyalty.
If you're one head of
a two-headed duopoly,
and you know your
product isn't very good,
what are you going to do?
You're going to insult
the other guy's product.
So if you see a
news show or a talk
show or read an article where
they're just constantly bagging
on the other side, you know
you're dealing with propaganda.
Keith Olbermann opens
his mouth, and out pours
a diatribe against Donald
Trump, or Michael Moore
opens his mouth and talks about
all the terrible conservatives
in the world.
Well, if you're a conservative,
you can naturally take offense,
but even if you are a liberal,
understand that propaganda
you agree with is the
most dangerous to you
and that the true
test of your firewall
is whether or not it can protect
you from propaganda that you
agree with.
And on the other side,
you get Rush Limbaugh
talking about the
liberals, and you
get Ann Coulter talking about
how awful the Democrats are
and how awful Obama is or was.
And yeah, you can know right
there what you're dealing with.
Now, most of the news sites--
CNN, US News & World
Report, the BBC--
these are going to be
reputable because they
have a lot at stake
with their credibility--
as I said, the
extremes, less so.
There's a very good website
that I've found I can recommend.
I have some concerns about it,
but it's called allsides.com.
And on allsides.com, they have
people reviewing and rating
the coverage of
various news sources
and saying where it falls
in the political spectrum.
That's very useful.
So they have a page where
you can look at the--
let's say you find an
article on Huffington Post.
What's Huffington Post?
So you look it up,
and lo and behold,
they're just left of center--
fine.
And so you know what
you're dealing with.
And they present news stories
from all across the spectrum.
So if you have an interest
in a particular story,
you can see everybody's take on
it and everybody's spin on it--
very useful website.
I have some concerns
about their rating system,
but all in all, valuable.
If you're looking
at motion pictures,
I did find a very
good site called--
oh, gosh, what was this thing?
I'll have to look it up.
But anyway, this
website mentioned
commercialism, consumerism
in its review of movies--
very good.
I think we need websites that
will list the amount of product
placement from no noticeable
to substantial to Michael Bay
was feeding on pleasant
habits that month
and will tell us in advance
before we go to see it
because they're very good
about slipping these product
placements in there in a
way that you won't notice.
And so I forget the
name of the website,
but I'll get back
to you on that.
So these are very
useful resources
that are available if
you're looking for them.
Does that help?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: One thing you said
that kind of surprised me--
you characterized kind
of the state propaganda
as the big brother
and the commercial one
as the little brother.
It kind of seems odd.
I think it looks like
way, way more money
is put into the
commercial propaganda,
and also the
political propaganda--
there is somebody who
has as much interest in,
who also has the resources,
in kind of countering that.
But in the case of
commercial propaganda,
where the main message of just
about every commercial that you
see is that, if you buy my crap,
then you will be loved, right?
That's the underlying message of
just about any commercial ever.
Yeah, but then there's
so much little--
I mean, of course, there
are people who tell you,
no, no, that's not
what's important.
They are out there.
But the amount of exposure that
they can cause to you, I mean,
they're much smaller.
So I mean, it would seem to
me it's the other way around.
The political one is
the little brother.
JACK NOLAN: Well, you
make a very good point.
And I agree that,
certainly, the corporations
tend to be investing
more money, and there
are fewer voices refuting them.
One of them would be, for
example, Buddhism-- the idea
of abjuring materialism.
I've often thought
that, if Buddhism
were to become the
major religion,
that our entire
economy would collapse.
Anyway, I was really
speaking more in terms of--
well, I created a Venn
diagram for the book,
which I wish I had brought
with me as a slide.
But the idea is that advertising
is a subset of propaganda,
so purist propaganda you find
in state-sponsored propaganda
like you'd find, say, in
North Korea or the kind
that you'd see coming
from the political parties
during election seasons.
The subset called
advertising is defined
as any message that directly
serves the economic needs
of the sender.
And so you see, advertising is
a subset of the larger rubric
of propaganda.
And to my way of thinking, it's
much the less interesting one.
I mean, I feel that we have
that we've inundated ourselves
with advertising to the
point of saturation,
and I find it depressing.
But I don't find it as
dangerous as the kind of thing
that we're seeing
now with fake news,
and that's why I'm so alarmed.
And honestly, when I wrote
my book back in 2015,
I had no idea that,
suddenly, fake news
and alternative facts--
a phrase designed
to make Orwell spin
in his coffin like a dervish--
that these would
become front page news
and would be dominating
the airwaves.
Really, in some ways, I
feel like I was pressing,
and I'm very grateful.
I wish things had
gone differently.
Anyway, so that's why
I feel that advertising
can be thought of as a little
brother to the larger scale
propaganda.
But you're right.
More funds go into advertising--
what we think of as
commercials-- than
go into political campaigns.
But political campaigns
are significant.
I know that, in a book
"The Assault on Reason"
written by Al Gore-- and I
cannot recommend this book
because Al Gore is very
partisan-- however,
he did write something that I
think is important for every
American to understand.
He wrote that-- and
he's a senator, mind,
so he's putting his credibility
on the line by saying this--
during the build up to
the second intervention
Desert Storm--
second intervention
in Iraq-- this
would be under George W. Bush,
not Desert Storm, excuse me.
When the Capitol
dome should have
been ringing with extensive
debate, most of the senators
were absent.
They weren't there
debating whether or not
our country should go to
war, which is, I think,
one of their major functions.
No, they were out soliciting
funds for their re-election
campaigns.
And what are they buying
with these solicited funds?
Propaganda.
They're buying commercial spots,
and they're buying buttons,
and they're buying posters.
So yes, propaganda,
once again, shows itself
as being one of our
society's major problems.
And if we take it upon
ourselves to make ourselves
more resistant to propaganda--
mind, there's no such
things invulnerability.
I'm as well as they
come in this field,
and I'm not invulnerable.
If we take it upon ourselves to
make ourselves more resistant--
and who knows?
Maybe all these senators
and representatives
will actually try other means
to get themselves re-elected
like doing their jobs well.
But that's why, I
feel, that advertising
should be considered
a little brother
to big brother propaganda.
Also frankly, big brother
propaganda came first.
Next question.
Now, fair disclosure-- I'd like
to introduce Abbie Melideo.
Abbie Melideo studied
profiling with the FBI
and looked over the
psychological side of my book
when it was in development.
She also designed
this spiffy cover.
ABBIE MELIDEO: Thank you, Jack.
OK, as a renegade
professional propagandist,
what can you do, if you
can do anything directly,
to target the fake news problem?
JACK NOLAN: In my
opinion, all we can do
is to put the firewall out
there like Windows Defender
or Adblock or any
other program that we
use to protect our computers
from outside tampering.
But this is one for our minds.
We didn't take it seriously,
and in our arrogance,
we thought, no, we're fine.
Propaganda doesn't affect us.
Yes, it does as any successful
ad man will tell you.
And Putin exploited that--
not good.
I think we need to be
teaching this material
at the high school
level, as I said.
I think we need to be
teaching Aristotelian logic
and argumentative logic at
the high school senior level.
And so that's why I'm
working my friend Doug
King as a high school teacher.
I'm hoping to turn this
into what's called a module,
like four-week standard module
and a two-week fast track
so that this can be available
to history teachers,
social studies teachers, and
English teachers, and in fact,
anybody who wants it--
it'll fit into anything
besides math, I guess--
so that this material can
be taught to our students.
I think, as I said before, the
buck stops with us this time.
The legislature is
not going to help us,
and the police
force can't help us.
It's up to us.
ABBIE MELIDEO: So are
you saying it's too late?
We have to start early
when they're kids?
JACK NOLAN: No.
No, I'm not.
I think that anybody
can be taught
and can teach themselves, when
exposed to the right material,
to think like a propagandist.
Ray Bradbury once
said, if you can't
find the book that you
want in the library,
sit down and write it.
Well, I looked around--
Edward Bernays, Gustave Le Bon--
God help us-- "The
Devil's Diaries"--
I had to wade that Parisians
sewer to write my book.
And now I've brought
his nuggets of wisdom
for you so you don't have to.
You're welcome.
It was hard reading.
But no primer existed, no
propaganda for dummies.
And so I thought, I'm
going to write this.
I created a primer based
upon my military training
to say, OK, here's a framework.
We can build on this.
We can make this work.
It's not too late.
We can give people the
special sunglasses.
We can show people
how I see the world.
And I think that it will be--
well, it won't be
absolute protection,
but it will be one extra layer
of protection, one more barrier
to prevent outside influence.
And that makes us more free
as individuals, as well
as a nation.
ABBIE MELIDEO: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I had one
other question myself,
which was how can we use
propaganda in our own lives
for our own benefit in a
positive way, not an evil way?
JACK NOLAN: Oh, I'm so
glad you asked that.
Let me give you some of
my favorite examples.
The tools of propaganda
are more properly called
the art of persuasion.
Now, we use persuasion
all the time.
If the tools of the
art of persuasion
are not used to directly
benefit you as the sender,
well, then they're
not propaganda.
But you can use these tools.
For example, I mentioned
using cigarettes and alcohol
in Casablanca to
enforce a new norm.
Well, let's look
at people who've
used that tool in other ways.
1967-- Bill Shatner's
"Star Trek"--
everybody remember that?
Well, you have a
milieu of the Mad Men,
where Caucasian
males run everything
and the women are consigned
to the switchboards
and the African-Americans
are consigned to the waiters.
And they come home from
that exhausting world, where
the Democratic National
Committee are literally
punch fests, and they
sit down and they
see this new workplace-- the
bridge of the enterprise, where
an African-American
woman and an Asian man
and an alien and a Russian
are all working together
in harmony.
And they're there because
of their accomplishments
not because of their race.
That was an inspiring
new message back then.
I mean, it seems kind of
quaint now because, that is,
we've kind of made
that a reality--
terrific.
But Gene Roddenberry
and Gene Coon
gave us this vision of a future.
Another example--
there was a man
who was a veteran of
the Pacific theater.
And then he went into
ad work, writing jingles
and so forth, and he got so
sick of it just like I did.
So he began writing
TV shows, and he was
known as TV's angry young man.
And after writing
some serious shows
and getting them
rejected by the censors,
he says, you know what?
I'm going to make a fantasy
show because fantasy shows
the censors don't care about.
And there's a fabulous
interview with him
with Mike Wallace, where Mike
Wallace comes down on him
for writing for a
lightweight genre.
What are you doing selling out?
No, I'm not selling out.
I'm making something amazing.
Well, that creator
was named Rod Serling,
and I'm sure you all
remember "The Twilight Zone."
Now, "The Twilight Zone"--
there's no interpreting.
He dominates his audience.
He tells you exactly what
he wants you to think
by the end of that show.
That's the mechanism of
manipulation at work.
This guy was using those tools
that he learned at advertising
to channel you to his
preconceived conclusions
all the way.
And God bless him for it--
really good stuff.
Norman Lear-- "All
in the Family"--
showing us Archie Bunker.
Do you want to be like this?
No, you don't.
Then don't think like him--
good stuff.
And we see this continuing
in the modern era.
We see television shows
that are put together
and motion pictures
by liked people, who
have an idea of what
they'd like the world to
be and want to promote it.
Most recently, and
please don't laugh,
I'm very fond of
"My Little Pony"--
the recent revision.
Lauren Faust is the
name of the creator,
and she created a lovely vision
of the world as it should be.
And if you dismiss the
unicorns and the pegasuses,
it's a really lovely vision.
So yes, this is
happening even today.
That's how you use
propaganda for the best.
Just remember, your objective
is not to profit yourself.
Your objective is to elevate
and ennoble your audience.
Hold on to that vision,
and you can't go wrong.
SPEAKER: Anything else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER: Oh, yeah.
JACK NOLAN: Please, please.
AUDIENCE: Well, since
you brought up Goebbels,
do you have any thoughts
on his big lie hypothesis?
JACK NOLAN: Oh, there's
one of my favorites.
It's a damned lie.
It doesn't exist.
The myth of the big lie
comes from a passage
in "Mein Kampf" in which
old Schicklgruber accused
the other side of using big lie.
And there's also a passage
in one of the motion pictures
that Goebbels created called--
not "Jud Suss"--
which one is it--
anyway, one of his
propaganda stories,
where one of his antagonists,
who's, of course, Jewish,
starts talking about big lie.
And the English accuse the
Germans of using big lie.
I read the entirety of Joseph
Goebbels personal diaries.
Never once did I catch him
bragging about actually
using the big lie.
And he gloats.
Trust me, he gloats.
No, I didn't catch him once
gloating about using it,
and I can tell you that
it's not a principle that
is taught at the USAJFK
Special Warfare Center
and School for Psychological
Operations and Warfare.
It's simply not taught.
It doesn't work.
While we're on things
that don't work,
and we're debunking myths,
subliminal advertising
from Dr. Joseph
Goebbels himself--
propaganda that is not perceived
is not propaganda at all.
Excuse me.
If you can't perceive
it, it doesn't work.
Now, can it trigger somebody
sitting in the audience
who's already hungry
and who likes popcorn
to go and buy some popcorn?
Maybe.
Can it persuade large groups of
people the way propaganda does?
Absolutely not.
If it could, my job would
have been a lot easier.
Does that answer your question?
Do we have anymore?
I'm thoroughly enjoying
myself, so please.
SPEAKER: Well, I think we
can wrap it up for now,
but thanks again for coming.
And I hope everyone
reads and enjoys
and takes lessons of the book.
JACK NOLAN: Thank you all.
It's been an honor.
[APPLAUSE]